oh man
is too much that's not too much there's
a weird feeling about sitting down and a
couple of mics again and looking at you
I just really haven't actually sat at
mics and looked at each other since our
last broadcast as so many years ago yeah
Wow yeah I feel it a little deja vu sort
of reverse reverse station you talked
about like doing Firefly and that never
came that never happened but man who you
are I know all you guys yes this is is
that Kevin Costner this is Christ Kevin
built-in cup himself never saw you did
not see King now it seemed him you know
what tourism the dog channel plays it
safer could go for it all and goes for
it all like he should like a hero I've
never seen it that's where you Renee
what it's always baby so I don't know if
you would like it honestly I always said
go for it be the hero yours like play it
safe try to par out we're gonna get a
bogey okay you know that I'm not trying
to bring up old stuff butters I don't
when I do it to me heading back sitting
here turn on the Golf Channel
tin cup playing all the time you really
you really should have seen it by now
Cheech Marin and the Cheech Marin is in
there so it's a fun films Crown Affair
but I'm having sort of a reverse déjà vu
where I am remembering or some we got
past hors d'oeuvres this is Marcus
Marcus as you know I well I mean as any
true fan of poundcake knows I am no
longer drinking since our last it's
going last broadcast alleged with the
betterment to the break that and so many
years and years and years and blah blah
blah and I'm tracking lawsuits and
domestic violence promises about us
getting back into doing this gig that
you would still abstain from any sort of
alcohol certainly while near on-air
there or affair and we decided we were
gonna do this I looked you in the eye
and I said you know what I'm done I'm
done without everybody I'm ready for us
again we're back and so here we are did
you it's not just us to water this back
it's you guys you guys are back now more
than anybody here's some questions
people gonna have one right out of the
gate where's Megan where is Megan I hear
you her contract still getting worked
out and I've trust that it'll get
figured out I trust will get figured out
she wants a third she wants to do this
yeah I talked her on the phone when she
was finally willing to listen to me and
I told her that you wanted to talk to
her see what I know better that Firefly
didn't happen she took it harder than we
did and we wanted it it wasn't it was
her baby right she's she's specific said
poundcake we do Firefly and when it
didn't happen she went off the rails and
we didn't talk to her for a while we
didn't see her for a long time but she
is safe anyone wants to know she's safe
and she is doing much better thanks
Marcus and she is had some coke to that
smell let me smell all right that's good
it is that's top-shelf Jack that's
top-shelf gentlemen Jack
usually my favorite drink but what are
we doing here now what are we doing here
today and that if you could see I know
you guys can hear them through the
microphones but if you could see there
are tens of thousands of people here we
are at the Hilton convention hall in
downtown Los Angeles don't look it up
they don't have a website already
checked
we're at the event remember they didn't
they didn't and you know what if you
guys hear it you're the reason you're
listening to show it's the reason
everybody who can hear me speaking in
this room right now is here
they said you sure you just don't need
like a part of part of the bar or a room
off the bar yeah a conference right no
you wait until you see the best podcast
fans of the world count Baker's pound
cake yeah
pound cake er which just to bring up
there are people still to our old
address when we were at the Beast rhymer
we're on the WR HL 1060 the Beast
tending to the Beast
morning early morning a.m.
our old program director Jeff Lyon I
feel first of all we should take this
moment part of this is reflective and we
want to say thank you to Jeff Leone gave
us a fresh start back in the old days of
radio when we would just do like many
specials and we kind of thought movies
would be a good idea of you and Jeff
gave us a chance but you guys need to
give Jeff a chance because if you keep
sending poundcake yes to WR HL 1060 WR
HL documents is still listed there you
can't eat any more he's going to die no
but night Jeff's not healthy without the
pound cake he does need it but let him
do it at his own discretion you guys
sending these a tweet I remember we
would come in in the morning yeah
Jeff whatever our we would have the
pre-show fist fight where we would kind
of talk about what we were gonna go over
that day we were covering you know like
a very special episode of Knott's
landing or we did the Jason verbal fist
fight for anyone's name from
home-improvement
jtt jtt Taylor Thomas Taylor come on
where he got sick we covered that
episode well remember when we I mean
just reflecting back growing pains God
do you remember that yeah
those I mean that feels like yesterday
but it also feels like forever ago Mike
Seaver yeah I am Leonardo DiCaprio a
young Leo remember it was like a runaway
amber when you said it you said that
kids got it and I said I said what do
you mean and you were which was your
which is how I always knew you were
drinking you always in oh yeah cuz I
wouldn't comment I would just ask
another question to keep the trip Megan
due to like she was she she might have
said it before I did that I was drunk
most days or about Leo DiCaprio being
super stoked both yeah yeah I wasn't
good at hiding I wore the same clothes
that's liquor under the bridge yeah but
anyway going just going back please stop
sending pound cakes to Jeff that is his
liquor and he is a good guy we still
golf we play nine we don't play 18 I'm
not good after the turn I'm not I'm not
fun to be around a lot of Kart time and
I'm at 50 to 60 just after nine I'm not
good at beyond that but if you're
sending him a pound cake
I speak for her down Megan and myself
when I say thank you so much it means a
lot to have fans who are that support of
the best things
yes you guys see us up here they're
ready for the announcement we're getting
there the clock is ticking you see the
timer behind me for anyone listening on
the radio now the live broadcast there's
a huge clock behind me that is
floor-to-ceiling digital counting down
til the announcement of what the next
show we're gonna be reviewing is because
this is bait guys not only we are not
seeing we are back the pound cake is
back we are back with a show it just
occurred to me we should maybe be saying
something to anyone who's just joining
us let me tell you what you have missed
okay and you've already realized you've
missed a party but no way there'll be
more parties to come with listen there's
so many parties and please get on our
Instagram pound cake pod and take a look
at some of the photos from tonight
because people are looking very good but
to any of you new people pound cake we
review TV shows and we took a huge
hiatus for personal reasons
and dramatic emotional flare ups that
occurred amongst the three of us and at
the station and with the station also
Jeff and Megan they're not talking he
threatened to kill her she is and all
that in their archives we don't need to
get into all of that we're gonna get all
that but I was a double-murder
threatening and it actually negates
itself and they're both free to you know
bother each other if they want to
because they both threatened to kill
each other but I point point being pound
cake is back and we are gonna be
reviewing another show and that clock is
still taken down but as soon as it hits
zero you can feel the energy for your
friends we're gonna be announcing what
the next time but I think you were on
the right track they're giving people a
little bit of history so mmm we both met
in the early 90s I was currently at the
time writing a weekly newsletter about
the the Gary Cole show midnight caller
that I was a big fan of and I feel like
that's how we found each other well I
was a fan that's how I got in I was I
had one of those karaoke machines right
at my house and I would set up
microphones and I would take blank
cassette tapes and I'm a record fake
radio shows and I remember I would send
them to anyone
that worked in media and I always was a
big you know growing up big movie review
guy right you know I love Siskel and
Ebert and I when I read your article and
what you were doing I saw this guy gets
it and this is someone I should talk to
and I remember I sent you one of my
cassette tapes which I I'm still
embarrassed by this it wasn't a
recording of me doing anything on the
karaoke but on the label it's set on the
label because I thought that's what it
was by accidentally left to record going
and I I don't even remember I think was
maybe an hour of me just yelling at my
dog's eye area which I don't have pets
anymore because of that your pitch and
your argument against those those dogs
is what sold me yeah cuz I'm like this
guy can talk about anything yes he can
go on a rant he can get deep I mean the
dogs any responded and a lot of times in
those early days
nobody was responding to us nobody no
yeah yeah so we knew you knew that was
gonna be and then I but you sent me a
letter about Gary Cole and and you said
from Cole 9 he's gonna keep you from
Cole two diamonds and I knew then when I
read that cold of Diamonds cuz I had
never thought of his name as like a Cole
like like Cole like you would put in a
stocking or whatever like that right
when you use that analogy I said this
guy is somebody I need to work because I
paint a picture I remember that's what
you told me you took your words and your
words or colors and it's like your dogs
were a canvas and it's like you threw a
lot of colors onto your dog's just to be
clear I did I never did hit my dogs they
are they were taken away because I was
aggressive with them verbally but as you
saw in my talent it was just I was
expressing my rant review this it was a
lot of water in the squirt gun as high
as I always like to say back in those
days I don't you use that term anymore
right obviously with you know this court
gun issue that happened in our third
year but that's percent so it ended up
being a real gun but then I knew that we
could work together yeah you know and I
feel that you're and I don't want to
bring up any bad stuff here yeah you
know your insistence that we
switch from talking about TV - going
into movies like things like Miller's
Crossing and Natural Born Killers it
just didn't have the legs right well and
I will go ahead and admit that then I
thought I was right I now know that I
was wrong right because it didn't have
the legs but I was like maybe we do
regarding radio shows about 10 you know
we do 10 radio shows that are about a TV
show one at one movie putting any legs
because the new movies were an hour and
a half two hours right you know now that
someone were three hours it kind of is
something for us to consider and I
remember when Kill Bill came out you
were like this is 500 as it was to
ballroom right you know I thought for
the most part it just didn't work I did
not right and then we said we had also
talked about doing comedy and we just
you know we started out with midnight
caller we should be doing we can handle
drama we can handle drama right so just
a you know where we are now we actually
have someone pretty special on the phone
oh you want to do it right now just this
one this one sneaky got him do you got
him on the phone at the sneak peak of
which network we're gonna be wet it's
because we as you know our language yeah
so we were at the Beast last time you
were at a.m. which was AM radio and then
we went to FM radio and now we're still
they're still gonna go FM radio which is
where we're right that's where we want
to be FM a.m. we weren't you know
getting is as big of a fan base but now
the network that we're gonna be with
well I'm hearing right now in the
producer that we've got him on the phone
okay so let's just let's let him go his
name is al how do you want to go ahead
and chat come on
do you all think how many podcasters
well I've heard wait thank you always
kidding me
a little comedian professional actor al
Madrigal and bill burr also professional
comedian professional actor yeah
president's of you heard him all things
comedy that's where we're gonna be flux
oh you guys when Marcus gets a second
he's gonna drop that banner and it's
gonna say ATC right across all things
calm I wanted to say it's so great that
you're here it's so great to have you on
the line with us is there anything else
you could tell our listeners about that
about this opportunity with all things
comedy I did think well thank you again
we also can't wait did I don't did
Alice's maybe we're getting a bad signal
it did seem like he kind of said maybe
he didn't think that we he got us you
know and the guys about us going there
you know we're giving you the news first
news out the gay the first announced is
where we're gonna be yeah they've got a
brand new beautiful studio that I'm here
in studio we're gonna be doing you're
sharing a mic for us that how are you
tonight right now and as you all know
we're gonna continue our our tradition
of allowing 10 to 15 or so audience
members in for the podcast to uh or the
radio show sorry I get caught up with as
you guys know I kind of went into the
podcast direction after the big hiatus
and breakup and it's okay it's alright
hey I still did with my karaoke machine
whatever but uh yeah we're at all things
comedy out I just got to ask you knowing
the drama that that has just sort of
been the bane of my existence and Dan's
and Megan the thing is what we're
talking about the NL you probably know
this is probably why you brought us on
when it comes to talking about the shows
yeah there's an though we nail that yeah
we know that there is some accoutrements
exact time along with that yeah as you
were saying well yeah I mean and because
of that I mean was there a part of you
that was like yeah maybe these guys are
a Gamble's I mean or or did you think to
yourself like oh you know it makes
perfect sense get these guys in the
booth let them talk about it let them
review TV what where was your head at oh
yeah
hey al Madrigal here for Maltese comedy
just want to welcome a damn anchor I
mean you are saying it's the same tone
every to out okay well I'm gonna drop
the call and well yeah maybe thanks al
so much thank you al Madrigal president
of all things comedy for taking a chance
on two guys and a two guys are the
greatest fans in the world I mean is the
chance they're applauding because
they're looking at the clock we've got
about two minutes to go till the big
announcement and you know what actually
you've got a letter I think did you not
receive a letter in the mail you know
well part of the reason that we got back
into this is for everyone that is here
in this room right now and everybody
who's listening to this and if this is
your first time listen to a pound cake
where you been hey well you know welcome
yeah it's what you're gonna hear it's
use the word family a lot just so you
know when we say family we're talking
about her fans cuz that's what we think
of our fans are the exact that's a big
letter that folded it's six times
because it's for like a two or a three
fold to be honest do you fold more or
less and I'd fold a little bit less than
that
really I do I do I like a one I do one
fold and if there's not an envelope big
enough then I don't send it you know as
a rule like as I think for yourself
because you know what I started doing
like I'll double knock yeah like um the
guy from Glengarry Glen Ross who double
knocks Alec Baldwin no the other Al
Pacino from Glen Al Pacino's no John C
McGinley he was in the Broadway no he
was also in the usual suspects
yes yeah did you hear what they're
saying they said Kevin Spacey I you just
threw it I just I I only said it cuz I
was like house of cards well before
there was a reprise but you you win and
yeah you know actually there is a prize
we have Dave o'clock from here in Los
Angeles he's an artist and he's doing a
lot of t-shirts and stuff for us we're
gonna be doing a huge giveaway if you
listen to the the very first episode is
when you get more of this information
but just to tease it and follow us you
can hang about
on social media with us on social media
that's your way to be an odd pound cake
pod get over to Instagram at pound cake
pod get on Instagram out pan out pound
cake pod retweet tweet talk about the
show but that person rather is gonna get
a Dave o'clock t-shirt that's all I'm
gonna say if you want more information
at one go ahead and did you still want
me to read the letter read that letter
here we go oh I didn't want ketchup no I
said I'm from Chicago don't give me
ketchup what did you want I just want a
corn dog with mustard okay let's get
into this one all right this letter is
now this is from somebody who's a bit
notable and then also a huge fan of the
show and this is the reason we're back
doing the pumpkin di love the Connor
celebrity
lands pretty family they are connor
hawke who as everyone knows tony hawks
nephew yeah but also this excuse me this
I get a little choked up the son of
Ethan Hawke he should be your agent if
you're here Megan and guys that's what
I'm fine with that yeah I am too what
happened where you been yep when you
coming back we all heard rumors about
Firefly and we knew that that was gonna
be the best best review show of Firefly
ever to be in existence would have been
but it never happened when are you
coming back are you guys off in the
fortress of solitude getting better I
hope that's the case
we wouldn't even review that that's not
a TV show that's a Superman well that's
easy
unless it's Smallville okay anyways
music all I want is for you guys to come
back I haven't spoken to my dad in two
and a half years but the last time we
talked it was about the pound cake
that's unfortunate I feel like you guys
are the tie that binds so many people
and their family relationships are you
you are the reason that people talk at
the dinner table say hi on a Sunday
night breeze and wave to each other as
they cross the street but not in a wave
that says hey I think I know you but a
wave that says yeah
listen to the pound cake - I hope that
you guys come back soon
if you do please let me know I'll be
there in that ballroom that night
standing in the back next to my dad
because you guys are doing a show again
oh my god they're here somewhere
oh man we do only have the one t-shirt
so they will have to decide yes you
larger a large that's why big Ethan it
this right here this is why this is why
we do it
that's why we've always done it for our
families yeah you know I mean yeah slash
you know fans like I already established
fans family this is all right well it
looks like we're about to be at it uh
we're gonna have to we're as excited as
I am I'm gonna try to get this room
quiet so they can hear this folks just
simmer down just a little bit ups hey
can you here we go alright folks I want
you to pin drop in you could hear a pin
drop you guys are so excited to know
what we're gonna be doing I would
actually like to introduce my partner in
entertainment to make this big
announcement for the two of us I'm just
happy that I can be a part of it and be
reunited again yeah ladies and gentlemen
give it up for Danville all right now
look in the pantheon of the show pound
cake we've done shows that have marked
popular culture Knots Landing falcon
crest then and this was I'll admit it I
wasn't a big fan at the time my
so-called life that was all you Rory
Scovel and we took on the drama and we
found our niche didn't we we even for
awhile went on with fanfiction just to
see how we thought that show should have
been closed out correctly here he said
by the way fan fiction is getting a
little too raunchy for me right just
tell a story tell a good story exactly
we've done other great hit shows like
Longmire Greg the bunny yep all right I
cannot believe what I'm about to say
next show the pound cake is going to be
reviewing and discussing on a weekly
basis for the entirety of its run is say
it Rory JJ Abrams / Stephen King's
11/22/63 it's gonna be on Hulu it's
gonna be streaming that'll be dropping
one Episode a week and we will be there
to watch and review and this is great
for you guys because you don't have to
worry about being in front of the old
tubeset know like back in the days you
know when we would we would cover shows
like MacGyver and things like that and
people would say I missed it guys it's
gonna be on Hulu you're gonna be able to
listen to us before you watch it listen
to us after you watch it we will be in
that room with you watching those
episode cake is back and it is here to
cover 11 times 463 know right let's talk
a little bit about the book yeah how we
came into it okay so here we go this
Stephen first time for us will we've
read a book I never was also a TV show I
never read books you know that about me
that's true uh I run into Megan Amram at
a coffee shop wishes she could be here
tonight we should get there to present
know she can make public appearances yet
based on the contract but I run into her
and I'm talking about Kennedy and I'm
talking about conspiracies and she goes
have you read Stephen King's 11/22/63 I
said I haven't what are we talking about
she's goes we're talk about time travel
mm-hmm which I'm about the Kennedy
assassination we're ready guys
we were LA milk coffee okay red flags
Amelia go time travel Kennedy's
assassination sounds like a giant ball
of cheese right that's what it sounds
like and she said well you gotta you've
got to check it out you got to read it
it's eight hundred something pages
daunting mm-hmm daunting yeah I see it
I go by it I say I'll read this over the
course of three years that's what you
thought that's what I thought yeah I
read it in two weeks maybe two to three
weeks couldn't put it down absolutely
loved it that's the first time I
realized Stephen King
is brilliant I should have already known
it he's a soul easy he's a legend right
in the author community this is some of
the same feelings I had and I so then
Dan comes over huge sports fan yeah take
it from there well we were watching was
it like the Stanley Cup it was a Stanley
Cup Finals for lack Hawks no I think it
was a second round or second round
because anyway they here are there when
we are it's finals was fine
I'll see up and um I come over and you
say hey do you read much I said yeah I'm
always looking for a good but you said
you need to read 11/22/63 that's right I
said what's it about and you got I'm not
gonna tell you anything about it yeah
good that's the date JFK was shot and
you're like fine whatever you say that
you knew that off the table yeah I would
have never known that shut up really I'm
not smart so there's a bit of a Marcus
so we sat down you said you've got to
read this book I'm not gonna tell you
anything about it just trust me that you
said trust me because I never read books
and I burned through this book yep so I
picked it up I started reading it and I
did I remember reading it on a Kindle
when I got to 50% I was sad because now
I knew I was half way today we're over
the hill yeah coming back down the other
side went back down the other side it is
I've gotten what three or four other
people to read the book yeah you have
told other people to read the book I've
told so many people yeah who knows who
actually listen and you know what you
said to me that same conversation went
the day that you said you should read
this book you go you go I was a quarter
of the way through the book I became
obsessed with this being it's got to be
a TV show and you're like I looked it up
to see who has the rights yeah thinking
that yeah nobody had a Stephen King
novel yeah and you found out right away
it's JD Abram Admiral project after a
little movie called Star Wars The Force
awakens and you were like this has got
it I wish so much I could be in the show
and we were already excited for the TV
show I was little did we think at the
time what if that's what brought
poundcake back we never never yeah I was
caught up in a book I said we don't
review books that I would even occur to
me that this could be something and then
when we found out it was going to be
happening on surprise surprise
Presidents Day folks that
right around the corner that's gonna be
February 15th that's a Monday dan you
know goes on does the research realize
all the episodes are gonna be dropping
every Monday on Hulu yeah well we said
well tell you what either Monday Tuesday
Wednesday there's some point in that
week we've got to review the episode we
saw because we've read the book yeah and
we're poundcake people would feel maybe
people be like oh it's a good show but
is it poundcake good yeah it has
poundcake reviewed it exactly and we're
not gonna let that happen where people's
doubt the quality of this show and
you've got something like Stephen King
who wrote a to the episodes can't wait
to see those eight the other two we'll
see what do we tell fans right now who
are listening who haven't read the book
what do we tell do we tell them to rush
and read the book I mean you go see a
movie a miniseries based on a book it
never adds up to the book I gotta be
honest there's so much rich storytelling
you know in this book I wonder if we're
gonna get all of that not to say it
won't be good right but will we get all
of that richness from the book in the
minister's what do we take what do we
tell people they have a week well yeah I
would say you could read it in a week if
you can read five it's good and I can't
do that I'm can't either
right but it's not April can yeah yeah
but if you're a reader on the Reg mm-hmm
you can read that in a week yeah not me
I did it but also dive into it now
you'll get far enough to where you'll be
ahead of the story I would say here's
something people need to know about the
first episode Dan's read you know Dan
has always been doing the research for
us since day one month shows Act
I was already writing that newsletter he
was constantly reviewing finding
resourcing he looks it up the first
episode released on Presidents Day the
fifteenth is there gonna be a two-parter
so it's gonna be 2 episodes 1 & 2 so
just so you know if you're going into
this miniseries I assume they'll all be
an hour long but this first one is gonna
be a two-hour event yeah and I'll tell
you what you're gonna want it to be a
two-hour event because I have a feeling
it is gonna just we're gonna dive right
in I think we're gonna dive right into
an amazing story James Frank
did you have doubts when you heard the
casting are you a Franco fan no here's
why I am a Franco fan but here's why I
didn't have doubts because he also tried
to buy those rights much like you first
action of wanting to see who was
developing he and I are similar in so
many ways he has two that means to me he
understands the material he gets the
story he wanted to be a part of it yeah
I mean he's asked her nominated actor
that's exactly him so he's an actor he
is a professional so I am I am very much
looking forward to him him sinking him
he's into it it feels good he's obsessed
with the book you know seen him like
smiling yes yeah and he knows how to use
him yeah he is an actor I think he's and
him being obsessed with this book mmm
that's what I want from whoever is gonna
be in this role right I want them being
obsessed with the book and the fact that
he is I'm excited I'm excited to hear
excited Steve I'm excited for us to be
back just as much as I am for the show I
am and we're gonna be and you know who's
probably not Jeff Liang takes back he's
gonna get a lot of power I mean people
were sending him pound cakes when we
were wre jobs when we thought we were
over we're sending him still at the
Beast Jeff is still at the Beast his
addressed
23:47 will hire Lane that they're still
there they're still studio 17 but do not
send any more pounds you know you will
kill this man yeah the lemon Y's are my
they're getting letters from Jeff's and
send more violently don't do that either
guys if J if Jeff is requesting the
pound cake yeah do not listen to him
that it's unsafe he's not eating
anything else yeah so I'm looking
forward to the show man and you know
we're gonna mix it up a little bit I
feel like every episode we're obviously
gonna cover the episode we're gonna talk
about what we you know what we loved
what we maybe we feel like they left out
a little bit yeah that's fine for people
who haven't read the book they don't
they didn't know what they didn't miss
so that's right matter and then we'll
also probably bring in some friends of
ours some some experts in the field of
whatever you want to discuss 100% when
we get this contract works out Megan is
gonna be here we're gonna have comedians
we're gonna have philosophers we're
gonna have
experts in the field of science and
cinema to come in and talk about the
logistics of the story but also
reviewing on their own and through us
the book the visual book you know when
you read a book the whole movie is in
your brain sure we obviously haven't
even seen the same movie by reading the
book exactly what are we gonna see now
that we know this is the definitive
visualization of this book what will it
look like we're gonna delve into every
single episode yeah and we're also we're
gonna get people's opinions and so if
you're wondering what can we expect from
poundcake
in the future this is it for 10 episodes
or so you will be listening to to us
talking specifically about 11/22/63 and
hopefully poundcake so there's probably
always gonna be a little extra there
there's always a little bit extra with
us you know that yeah with us I had a
restraining order against you that I was
able to have waived for so night show
but we'll figure look that'll all get
worked out hopefully I am hoping you are
able to get that waived you also the
according to judge you are the first
person who served as the defendant and a
witness for the prosecution in your own
restraining order hearing because you
felt like you maybe needed to be a
little bit as well but I feel like we're
past those days but I'm so I'm gonna
have that worked out by the time we do
we're gonna go to the courts we're gonna
talk to the lawyers we're gonna see if
we can get that taken care of but
hopefully we will be in the studio
together if not do not fear you're gonna
still get the the pound cake package as
we always call it one of our shows and
just to send the listeners out off and
all the people here who came out tonight
and obviously please go on Twitter
don't kick fun guys thank you so much
for really keeping it down while we go
thank you very much a very attentive go
on Instagram
pound cake pod look at the pictures from
tonight's Hardy I mean it's absolutely
you'll see the ones from delicious and
you will not want to miss the next you
won't want to miss it and we're thinking
about dropping some classic photos of us
sort of in the the days of old when
we're in the booth together but
you know the that's all getting started
as you know we've deleted every almost
everything we've ever done and we're a
lot of those three but a lot of that
deleting was done out of spite but
neither one of strumming fingers know
when it was okay yeah they're not gonna
pointing fingers but people have asked
as you know with poundcake we always
have a brand new theme song in depending
on what you go we're doing and I was
able to work a little bit of magic and
work a little bit of paperwork and
numbers and moolah you know how to get
things done I know how to get things
done through the alleyway if you know
what I mean with a band
they're called the winter sounds they're
on iTunes they have videos on YouTube
they are fantastic and we were able to
get them to do the theme song for pound
cake and 11/22/63 goodness I'm not
kidding you I haven't even heard this
this is about to be Megan doesn't know
oh my god you guys are all in for a
treat yeah everyone is in for a treat
okay
so ladies and gentlemen I want to say
thank you and I can't wait to get back
on the airwaves and talk with you guys
in in a week or so and talk about what
we saw for that first two episodes of
11/22/63 my name is Rory Scovel my name
is Daniel Van Kirk we're gonna play that
song go out on this guy's please get
home safely tonight Rory good night
you